[Music]
hi I'm Neil Mueller on the geographic
expansion team we build the technical
infrastructure that powers Google and
Google cloud platform this includes new
regions points of presence solar and
wind farms and terrestrial and submarine
cable networks I'm here today to tell
you about a new amazing region in Sydney
it's now open this isn't our first
region in Asia we also have Singapore
Taiwan and Tokyo our global network
connects all of our regions together
along with our hundred points of
presence all over the world
the Google Network is the largest
network of any public cloud provider now
that I've told you about our network
let's talk about the Sydney region
itself for the first time ever GCP users
can process and store data locally in
Australia as you can see from this list
of services the services include compute
big data storage and networking you can
find a whole lot more about the services
in Sydney at cloud google.com slash
about slash location in short the Sydney
region has everything that you need to
build and scale what's next and now
let's hear from our local team in
Australia to learn what this new region
in Sydney means for local customers hi
I'm Angela Joyce I'm the head of
customer engineering in Australia New
Zealand my team and I helped customers
in the adoption of Google cloud platform
solutions to meet their business needs
and helping them innovate into the
future we have thousands of customers on
our cloud platform the likes of all
votes Halfbrick in gogo news called
Fairfax service New South Wales and PwC
to name a few customers such as rent a
cool initial are using our data flow and
publish and subscribe services for IOT
solutions for facilities monitoring for
up to 10,000 customers others such as
Monash University are using our Google
App Engine as an application service
platform and digital natives like
papercut are using bigquery for
analytics and reporting
what really excites me about the Sydney
region is that it will allow customers
to store and process data in Australia
our performance testing of the Sydney
region shows 40 to 90 percent reductions
in the round-trip time
latency when serving customers in Sydney
as compared to other regional options in
Taiwan Japan Singapore and India I think
customers are going to love having an
even faster and more local Google cloud
GCP has been helping customers in
Australia New Zealand for more than five
years and with our sales teams based in
Sydney Melbourne Brisbane Auckland we
have always had a local point of
presence to connect our local customers
to Google cloud solutions and now even
more so that we have a local DCP region
so we're really excited to see what
customers we'll be building them and
finally the Google cloud summit is
coming to Australia in September so I
look forward to seeing you all there
that's right thanks there's never been a
better time to get up and running with
Google cloud platform we think GCP is a
smart secure cloud to help move your
business forward and with our new region
in Sydney or right next door we're
excited to see what you're going to
build in the Sydney region and remember
to check out the Google cloud home page
for upcoming summits near you thanks
you